[Musique]
attends la colère et est ouest
du remue ménage du remue ménage à
benjamin à qu'on s'était très bien
trempé dahouët kelly à manger douze
mille 900 calories en moins qu'elle ait
pas la nouvelle copine de tunisie à bien
vous êtes vus là-bas
rencontré hier à merveille pour lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça monte ça monte en lever le chapeau et
lunettes le chef ce machin t-shirt quoi
comme qu'on l'avait bouffer avec ne
valent en effet un abri quelques
polémiques
je voudrais que j'ai le bras long
j'étais bagage contient
des shows faisait mauvais genre pour sa
part les filles sont jolies
à ses pieds les cantons à revenir sur
les contreparties de temps à revenir et
votre énoncé n'y ait ni élu ni oui ni ne
fait pas comme ça et mehdi baala
ma mère m'avait fait une course il va
pas là bas donc vos pronos parfois des
cépages dits justin elle visait bien
[Musique]
eh bien c'était la voiture c'est
vraiment la personne de la crise
productrice boloss vont le voleur finira
pas faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là parce que dans ce film respecte pas
je peux te présenter
je l'attendais pas ce week end chez nous
connaissez vous regarde vous les
raconter
voilà donc il a fait depuis deux jours
le problème c'est que je limite
maintenant j'avais de plus la vie
[Musique]